five years of tax scandals of
revelations starting with lux leaks
we thought we'd reached a climax with
the Panama papers only to discover the
shocking news later with the Paradis
papers and comics files
S&D was a key actor in the investigation
into the tax scandals here's our story
of this mandates five for Tax Justice
[Music]
it's a story of loopholes appearing as
soon as the old ones are filled of an
outdated EU law system always lagging
behind bankers and intermediaries
innovations shocked by the scale of the
tax evasion and tax fraud that has been
going on for years
the S&D took the initiative as a result
the European Parliament set up a series
of committees to investigate tax crimes
in Europe in the latest committee tax
three all forms of tax avoidance were
dressed as Asian fraud and financial
criminality the loss for national
budgets is huge eight hundred and twenty
five billion euros every year which
could be used to finance infrastructure
in health transport or the ecological
transition essential to citizens big
corporations alter rich people they are
not paying their fair taxes they are
hiding their fortune away in tax havens
they are costing big economic loss to
our societies because they're not paying
taxes what the text committees do is to
find ways to stop the race to the bottom
and make everyone pay their fair share
somehow it's a to-do list for the
ministers for the member states for the
governments to follow what we reach as
European parliamentarians government's
argue they don't have money well they
don't have money because they are
letting the money go abroad into tax
havens because they don't actually take
measures to indeed ensure tax
sovereignty at the European level among
the variety of the legal practices being
described in the report one fact may
alone describe how vital a reform of tax
law has become
if the same criteria for exotic tax
havens are applied to Member States the
EU still counts five Malta Cyprus
Ireland Luxembourg and the Netherlands
backs dumping absolutely violates and
distorts fair competition within the
internal market in order to
counter-attack tax-free defines a clear
and concrete course of action
companies should pay their taxes where
they make their profits in a public and
transparent way money-laundering should
be dealt with seriously to discover
where the money is hidden three ports
where works of Arts and precious goods
are hidden should be forbidden a
harmonization of the vit system should
be undertaken to prevent the loss of 50
billion euros per year to organized
crime and terrorists also a digital tax
should be set up and revenues derived
from advertisements from tech giants
like Facebook and Google we need
something like a joint base concern with
the whole definition of corporate taxes
within European Union so somehow
something that is consolidated since the
beginning of the legislature with Pierre
Mozgov EC and the commission des indes
have had a natural allowed to push for
their agenda yet the council where the
tax law is voted on unanimously has
blocked progress on key issues DSM D and
Commissioner Pierre Muscovy seen call
for the inspiration of qualified
majority voting on tax issues to see
different official keep a photo
nationalism a physical setting issue
heimo the show V the tactility
competitivity classroom opera the
current socialist to see in the modern
European public getting some of all tax
dream has finally been adopted by a very
large majority yet some elements such as
a minimum effective corporate tax rate
of 18% was voted down by the
Conservatives
floral and what havoc disagreements
Lucian applicants Yoshida who gets away
no cosmetic oxen honk massive if you're
ugly not romantic homage sorry the body
millions of year this week a little more
cut only prometida known as you come
back if the minister's would put all
these demands of us parliamentarians of
us from the Socialists and Democrats
into practice this would be a revolution
of text justice so somehow let's go for
that we have to lead the fight for Tax
Justice continues for the SMD in order
to have everyone pay their fair share of
taxes
[Music]